شكرا لك ريم مشاهدينا الكرام اذا اهلا بكم
في هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي نخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان البدايه
بالعناوين
الاليه الثلاثيه في السودان تناشد طرفي
النزاع على الاستجابه لتمديد الهدنه وتقول
ان الشعب في حاجه ماسه لها
البنك المركزي السوداني يؤكد ان اموال
المذيعين في الجهاز المصرفي امنه وان
عمليات السرقه لا تؤثر عليها نحو اليوم
العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول
العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق
السودان الى عدد من الدول العربيه في
بورسودان حيث مركز الاجلاء الرئيسي عالقون
يطالبون بالخروج
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى ايضا
قائد يشكو نقص الذخيره ويحذر من ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد قد يشكل ماساه لروسيا
[موسيقى]
قبل انتهاء الهدنه الخامسه في السودان
اعلنت قوه الدعم السريع في عن هدنه سادسه
اذا هذه الهدنه كسابقاتها لمده 72 ساعه
تبدا من منتصف الليله لفتح الممرات
الانسانيه وقبل قليل اعلن الجيش السوداني
موافقته على التمديد الاليه الثلاثيه
بالسودان كانت دعت البرهان وحمتي للموافقه
على التمديد وقف اطلاق النار لثتين وسبعين
ساعه لان السودانيين بحاجه ماسه لهذه
الهده واكدت الاليه الثلاثيه ان وقف النار
سيمهد الطريق لمحادثات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع قبل ذلك تبادل طرفات صراع
الاتهامات الدعم السريع يقول ان الجيش لا
يحترم الهدنه والجيش ايضا يقول انه يبسط
سيطرته على معظم الخرطوم
تم التزامنا بهدنه ايضا هنالك طائرات
تتحدى هذا هذه الهدنه وتضرب في الاطراف
وتضرب وتحوم حول مواقع الدعم السريع ما
يسمع من رصاص ومضادات الدعم السريعه
الارضيه تتصدى لهجوم طيران لكن على ارض
الواقع في ولايه الخرطوم في كل مدينه فلا
توجد قوات مشاه للجيش او قوات تتحرك من
مكان الى مكان للجيش هذه مساله حسمت منذ
ايام لا يوجد تحرك للجيش داخل ولايه
الخرطوم السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
البرتغال غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير ومتغير الاخير الذي تمثل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتوائه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس ليس صحيحا
هذا ومددت سلطه الطيران المدني السوداني
اغلاق المجال الجوي امام حركه الملاحه
لمده اسبوعين اي حتى الثالث عشر من مايو
المقبل واستثنى قرار تمديد اغلاق الاجواء
طائرات الاجلاء والمساعدات الانسانيه على
ان يتم ذلك باذن مسبق من سلطه الطيران
المدني السوداني
من جانبه قلل ممثل الخاص الامين العاملي
السودان قال انه لا توجد الى الان مفاوضات
مباشره بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني
ليس هناك مفوذات مباشره
هناك تحضيرات
لمحادثه
او
لتحضير محادثه
بين الجانبين
فبعض الدول الاقليميه والدوليه
تشتغل مباشره
مع جهتين
هذه الجهود انا شخصيا كمان باتصال مباشر
مع جانبي
فان شاء الله
سنرتب باقرب وقت ممكن
لقاء مباشر بين ممثلين
القوات المسلحه والام السريع كي نصل الى
اكثر من هدنه الى وقف اطلاق نار منظم اكثر
باليه مراقبه
معنا من الرياض الصحفي السوداني في جريده
الشرق الاوسط فتح الرحمن يوسف وساد فتح
الرحمن اهلا بكم معنا هدنه تكاد تنقضي بعد
ساعات واعلان عن تمديد اخر او هدنه جديده
بعد منتصف هذه الليله قد يتساءل المرء ما
نفعل هدى اذا كانت لا تصمد او على الاقل
تشوبها الكثير من الخروقات
نعم شكرا لك للاستضافه تحيات لك
الكرام
نعم يعني نشهد هدنا تلو الهدنه هذه حقيقه
وهي يعني تخدم يعني حيث ضيق جدا
من العمليه
برمتها يعني الوضع الانساني في حدود ضيقه
جدا وما تلبسان تنهار او يعني يبدا كل طرف
يعني يتهم الاخر بانه خرق الهدنه وتشتغل
الاشتباقات من جديد وكان جازيت مع غزيت
فهذه المساله مستمره يعني للاسف الشديد
وبالتالي يعني طالما ما زالت هناك
الاشتباكات يعني
مستمره في مواقع اخرى وما زال هناك يعني
يعني محاوله لكسب تحقيق شيء من الاتصال
على الارض من الطرفين
وتظل الهدنه دائما في مهدده يعني هذه
مشكله طيب في ظل يعني هذه الهشاشه التي
تتميز بها الهدى استاذ فتح الرحمن هل ترى
املا في ان يجلس عبد الفتاح البرهان وحمتي
الى طاوله واحده للحوار لانهاء هذا القتال
ام لا ترى هذا
رهنا ربما بانتصار طرف على الاخر
واعتقد يعني اعتقد خلال هذه الفتره اللي
دخلنا عليها في الاسبوع الثالث
والاشتباقات بين الطرفين اعتقد انه كل طرف
استطاع ان يختبر الطرف الاخر الى ماذا
يمكن ان يتحكم ويسيطر على الحيز محدد من
ويحقق بعض المكاس اعتقد هناك رغبه من
الطرفين للحوار وان كان الاشتباقات ما
زالت هي سيده الموقف
ولكن طبعا في ظل الضغوط الدوليه وفي ظل ظل
رغبه الاشقاء في السعوديه
بمساعده الامريكيين نعم اعتقد هناك مجال
للدفع العمليه لعمليه الحوار الى الامام
واعتقد ان الطرفين لديهم الرغبه وان كانت
الرقبه هي تظلطه الى يعني في ظل
الاشتباقات التي تدور الان نعم
واعتقد هناك مؤشرات هناك مؤشرات لاداره
الحوار
وهناك يعني بعض الملامح اللي هي تتمثل
منصرا في
وجود
المفرد السوداني اللي هو وكيل وزاره
الخارجيه من قبل البرهان الموجوده الان في
السعوديه
والذي قابل يعني معالي وزير الخارجيه
وتناقش حول الاوضاع واعتقد
الحوار هو الموضوع الاساسي في هذه الزياره
اعتقد هناك رغبه وهناك رغبه داخليه
وخارجيه رغبه داخليه وخارجيه ولكنها يعني
تصطدم بالداخل وما يحدث فيه ندخل اسبوعا
ثالثا من هذه المعارك بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع استاذ فتح الرحمن رئيس
الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله حمدوك
حذر من نيروبي من اندلاع حرب اهليه في
السودان وبان هذه الحرب ستشكل كابوسا
للعالم هل تتفق مع حمدوك بان السودان ذاهب
الى حرب اهليه
اتفق تماما اتفق تماما لان الاشتباكات
التي حدثت في نيالا بالجنينه
على اثرها قتل
زياده عن تسعين 96 قتيلا في هذه
الاشتباكات التي يعني دارت في الجنينه غرب
السودان في دارفور تحديدا
وكانت بدافع من بعض القبائل نحو بعض
المواطنين في بعض المواقع
ويعني ثلاثها او تزامت معها عمليات نهب
وسرقه وقتل وكذا وهذه بالتاكيد ستعود الى
حرب اهليه طاحنه لتقضي على الاخضر واليابس
بالتاكيد يعني هذا مؤكد وبالتالي يعني
لابد من الطرفين يعني انتبهان لهذه
المساله لان نحن في السودان والسودان يعني
هو بشكل الحالي صار كانما هو امانه في بين
يدي هؤلاء المتصارعين يعني نحن كشعب يعني
حقيقه النظر تحت رحمتها هؤلاء الذين
يتصارعون على في داخل الخرطوم
وهناك مناصرين مناصرين للدعم السريع
ومناصرين للجيش طبعا الفرق بين الاثنين
مناصرين للجيش هم المؤسسه
العسكريه من الجيش والمناصرين لدعم السريع
هم الجنود الذين ينتمون الى قبائل متفرقه
ايضا يستطيع ان يساندوا الجيش في القوات
الدعم الصريح في تلك المواقع اذا حصلت هذا
الاستواء وهي حاصل الان هي نوال حرب اهليه
بالتاكيد يعني وهذا شيء يعني مخيف ومهدد
للاصدار شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ فتح الرحمن
يوسف الكاتب الصحفي السوداني في جريده
الشرق الاوسط
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى
بسامبال المواطنين والسكان في المنطقه
ومناطق المجاوره
مباشره من النيل شيلوا مويه بتاعه
[موسيقى]
الناس بتعاني شديد جدعاني
تتحرك فيهم المناطق الصينيه هناك كلها
تجيبيه وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
قلل متحدث باسم اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه
اطباء السودان الدكتور سيد محمد عبد الله
للعربيه قال ان الوضع كارثي في المستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه مشيرا الى ان 70% من
المستشفيات خارجه عن الخدمه اما
المستشفيات المتبقيه فتعمل بشكل جزئي
للطوارئ وللاصابات الوضع كارثي في هذه
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
حتى كما تعلمون سبعين بالمئه من هذه
المستشفيات خرجه تماما عن الخدمه 61
مستشفى من جمله 86 مستشفى في منطقه
الاشتباكات توقفت تماما عن العمل وهذه
الخمسه وعشرين مستشفى التي بقيت تعمل بشكل
بعضها او معظمها يعمل بشكل جزئي ويقدم
زعافات اوليه
للطوارئ وللاصابات
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عن
ارسالها لاول شحنه مساعدات انسانيه من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الى بورسودان وقالت
اللجنه في بيان يعني ان شحنه المرسله
مؤلفتنا من ثمانيه اطنان من المعدات
الجراحيه لدعم المستشفيات السودان ومتطوعي
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني بالاضافه
الى مواد تخدير وادوات تضميد ولوازم خياطه
الجروح وغيرها من المعدات الجراحيه التي
يمكن ان تستخدم لعلاج الاف الاشخاص الذين
اصيبوا بجروح جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
تتابع مباشره من مطار جده الدوليه مع
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان اهلا بك
معنا ضعنا في صوره جهود السعوديه المستمره
لاجلاء العالقين من السودان
اهلا بك بعدما تم اجلاء عدد كبير من
الرعايه الهنود من السودان عبر السلطات
السعوديه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحري او
حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وحتى
كذلك عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي اليوم يستعد
185 مواطن هندي السفر الى بلدانهم بعد ان
تم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بذلك
اليوم كاميرا العربيه سوف ترافق هذه
الرحله او هؤلاء الرعايه حتى وصولهم الى
الطائره ايرباصه رقم الطائره السبعه ثلاثه
هذه الطائره موجه الى الهند وتحديدا الى
مدينه كوتشين الهنديه نتحدث انه سوف
تستغرق الرحله قرابه الخمس الساعات نتحدث
عن هذه الرحله هي الرحله هي الخامسه التي
سوف تتوجه الى الهند بعد ان اقلعت خمسه او
غادرت خمسه طائرات من مطار الملكه عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده الى الهند الان سوف
السعوديه كما مكثوا في السعوديه بعد
وصولهم من السودان
ساعه فقط بعد ان اجلتهم السلطات السعوديه
من ميناء بورت السودان الى مدينه جده عبر
السفن البحريه السعوديه او حتى الارسال
يتقطع قليلا
لمربعين ساعه قلت لانه الارسال يتقطع يعني
يصلنا متقطع
في القطار
نعم 48 ساعه نتحدث عن قرابه 1500 مواطن
هندي تم مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم بعد ان تم
اجلائهم من السودان وصولا الى مدينه جده
عبر قاعه الملك فيصل حتى عبر ميناء جده
الاسلامي او حتى كذلك عبر قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه ولا تزال العمليات الاجلاء
مستمره من السودان الى مدينه جده وفي ظرف
48 ساعه يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر
الخاصه بهم ومنحهم تاشيرات استثنائيه من
قبل المديريه العامه للجوازات حتى يتسنى
هؤلاء حتى يتسنى لهؤلاء الرعايه السفر الى
بلدانهم في بعض الموقف الانساني او
المواقف الصعبه التي عاشها هنالك في
السودان اليوم الحكومه السعوديه تعمل على
تقديم جمله وحزمه كبيره من البرامج
والخدمات للتسهيل على هؤلاء الرعايه حتى
ان يصلوا الى بلدانهم بالتنسيق مع
حكوماتهم نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره تعمل على
اجلام الحكومه الحكومه السعوديه منذ بدء
الاشتباكات المسلحه هناك في السودان الجيش
السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع في ظرف
ثواني محدوده سوف نصل الى طائره ايرباص
رقم سبعه ثلاثه سبعه هذه الطائره الهنديه
التي تسمى
شركه خطوط هنديه هي المسؤوله والتي سوف
تقوم بنقل هؤلاء الركاب الى مدينه كوتشين
الهنديه وهي الرحله الخامسه التي تغادر من
مدينه جده الى المدن الهنديه ايضا الرعايه
الصينيين كانوا يغادروا قبل 48 ساعه من
الان وكان عددهم قرابه الثلاثه وسبعه
واربعين مواطن صيني وكانت هذه هي اعداد
كافه الرعايه الصينيه الذين غادروا الذين
وصلوا من بورتسودات تحديدا الى السعوديه
وكان قد غادروا قبل 48 ساعه الان كما
نتحدث نشاهد اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء الرعايه
نتحدث عن عائلات واطفال واعداد كبيره جدا
من هؤلاء الرائعين الذين نعاشوا تفاصيل
اوقات الصعبه جدا خلال الايام الماضيه
عندما كانوا في السودان اليوم الحكومه
السعوديه قامت باجلاها هؤلاء الرعايه
وايصالهم الى جده وبعد ذلك تقديم كافه
الخدمات
التموينيه والاعاشيه والطبيه والصحيه
لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك منحهم تاشيرات
استثنائيه حتى يتسلل هؤلاء الرعايه انهاء
الاجراءات السفر الخاصه بهؤلاء حتى ان
يصلوا الى بلدانهم هذا التعامل يتم
التعامل به مع كافه الرعايه بمختلف
جنسيتهم واديانهم ايضا الان متوقع ان
وصلنا الى هذه الطائره
نعم موقع الان قد يفتح هذا الباب الان
اسمحوا لنا بس نقدر نعدي الان نعم ممكن
تفضل زميلنا مصور عصام
اذا نحن معك سلطان
نتابع المسافرين الذين
استقلوا الحافله هذه دفعه من
الرعايه
الهنود الذين جرى اجلؤهم من السودان
عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه حيث يومين
هناك 48 ساعه وتم منحهم تاشيرات خاصه بسبب
يعني هذه الاجراءات او هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه التي يمر بها السودان كما
تابعنا معك هم الان
حتى يستقلوا الطائره ويعودوا الى الهند من
السعوديه
نعم نتحدث عن
1369 مواطن هندي كان قد غادروا من مدينه
جده الى المدن الهنديه مع هذه الرحله التي
علمتها
185 شخص سوف يقوم بمغادره
عبر هذه الطائره هي سبايسي جت طائره هنديه
سوف تقوم بنقل 185 شخص في رحله الى مدينه
كوتشينه الهنديه في رحله سوف تستغرق قرابه
الخمسه الساعات نتحدث انه عمليه الاجراء
من السودان الى جده مستمره الى وقت انتهى
المغادره من جده الى نعم وشكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المواكبه اذا هؤلاء خرجوا سالمين
من السودان ووصلوا الى السعوديه
ومكتوا فيها اذا والان نتمنى لهم الوصول
سالمين الى بلادهم الى الهند نبقى في
المتابعه الان معنى من قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه في جده ايضا المراسل مراسلنا
هاني نصفيان هو على متن الطائره على ما
يبدو طائره اخرى لاجلاء رعايه هاني
التفاصيل من عندك
نحن بدا طائره ايرباص 319 التابعه للقوات
الجويه الباكستانيه وهي بالفعل هي طائره
مدنيه
وتحمل على متنها 140 شخص من رعايه باكستان
الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان عبر سفن
السعوديه طبعا هؤلاء الذين الان يغادرون
الى من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
مدينه جده الى مدينه كراتشي تحديدا وهم تم
انهاء اجراءاتهم بعد ان تم ايضا تسهيل
ومنحهم التاشيره او تاشيره الدخول التي
تمكنهم من الدخول من الاراضي السعوديه حتى
خروجهم ومغادرتهم الى بلدانهم طبعا هناك
كنم ايضا بحضور القنصل العام الباكستاني
وكذلك عدد من القيادات الموجوده في قاعده
الملك عبد الله الج وايضا هنا عدد من
الرعايه الذين يقومون
[موسيقى]
والعدد من الرعايه الذين الان تم انهاء
اجراءاتهم فقط في انتهاء
المراحل الاخيره من التشييك النهائي على
هذه الطائره وبعد ذلك سوف يغادرون طبعا
هذه الرحله هي تعتبر الرحله رقم تسعه
واربعين التي تنفذ في قاعده الملك او
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وهي من ضمن
الرحلات الجويه التي تقوم باشراف عليها
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه هناك
طائرات عسكريه اجنبيه وكذلك تجاريه اضافه
الى طائرات عسكريه ايضا تابع القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه قامت باجلاء
الكثير والعديد من الرعايه من جنسيات
مختلفه لا ننسى ايضا هناك في الجهه الاخرى
الموانع وكذلك الاسطول
مستمر ولم يتوقف هناك ايضا اليوم كانت
وصلت الى قائده الملك عبد الله الجويه
رحلتين قادمتين من بورسودان وتم اجراءهم
والان هم يقومون بانهاء اجراءاتهم الاولى
كانت طائره باكستانيه عسكريه من الهند
والاخرى كانت ايضا عسكريه
وباكستانيه وايضا يتوقع ان تصل ايضا خلال
الساعات القادمه طائره اخرى لكن سوف يتم
التعرف عليها بشكل اوضح وايسر وافضل ربما
هذه الازمه في السودان جعلتنا نكتشف ان
هناك العديد يعني اعداد كبيره من الرعايه
الاجانب يعملون هناك في السودان صحيح يعني
من خلال اعداد الرحلات الكبيره كما ذكرت
49 رحله حتى الان فقط من قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه
ما طبيعه النشاطات او الاعمال التي كان
كانت تقوم بها هذه الجاليه مثلا الجاليه
او هذه الرحله من
رعايه باكستانيين ما طبيعه الاعمال التي
كانوا يقومون بها في السودان
[تصفيق]
هؤلاء الرعايه سواء من تحديده من الجنسيات
الاسيويه كانت هناك شركات تابعه وكانت
تعمل مع الحكومه
في السودان سواء في مصانع الرخام او كذلك
مصانع الاسفنج وبعضهم ايضا في مصانع انتاج
الطلاء فالمعظم كان يتحدث هناك ايضا الجزء
الاخر كان يعمل في مشاريع مقاولات وكنت
اتحدث معهم هل لماذا اختاروا السودان
تختار الجنسيه الاسيويه تحديدا لماذا لم
يكن هناك ايضا بالنسبه لايدي العامله في
السودان وهم كثر
فالاجابه كانت بحسب يعني صاحب خبره من احد
الرعايه الموجودين قال ان تكلفه العيد
العامله بالنسبه او الاجر لدى العامل في
اسيا ارخص بكثير من اجره
اليوميه بالنسبه
للمواطنين في السودان فلذلك كان هناك عدد
رعايه طبعا هؤلاء عدد
بسيط هناك الالاف بحسب كحديثهم وكلامهم
ايضا بالنسبه رعايه باكستان تحديدا تبقى
قرابه الالف شخص او الف ايضا ممن سوف يتم
اجلاؤهم خلال اليومين او ثلاثه ايام
القادمه اما عبر السفن السعوديه او تبع
القوات البحريه السعوديه او كذلك عبر
طائرات عسكريه باكستانيه صحيح وبالتالي
يعني هذه الحرب يهاني قطعت بارزاق هؤلاء
الالاف من العمال الاسيويين الذين يعني
كان السودان مصدر رزقهم كما ذكرت يعني في
ان كان في معامل الرخام او في اعمال
المقاولات والبناء في السودان هم يعودون
الان الى اراضيهم يعني او الى بلادهم كما
تبعنا مع علامات طائره تجري رعايه الى
دوله باكستان وقبل قليل
زميلنا السلمي كذلك كان مع طائره اخرى
تجلي رعايه باتجاه الهند مهاني نحن الان
في الاسبوع ندخل اسبوعا ثالثا من
المواجهات العسكريه في السودان هل من
معلومات الى متى ستستمر عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب عبر السعوديه
طبعا لا يوجد موعد محدد دقيق ولكن في
الحقيقه ما نشاهده نعم محدد ولكن ما
نشاهده من خلال الاستمرار واستمرار عمليات
الاجلاء سواء في الجسر الجوي او كذلك في
الاسطول البحري واضح جدا ان هناك مازال
المزيد لا ننسى ايضا صهيب هناك ايضا مساله
اخرى هناك بعض الرعايه من جنسيات عربيه لا
يوجد لديها قنصليات او سفارات وكذلك لم لا
تستطيع الخروج من السودان بسبب ايضا حملها
لبعض الوثائق او لا يتوج او لا يوجد ايضا
لديهم قنصليه يتواصلون معها عموما اليوم
ممكن ان نتحدث مع
مدير عام الجوازات في السعوديه الفريق
سليمان اليحيى والذي تحدث للعربيه ان
هؤلاء الرعايه الذين ياتون يمنح لهم
تاشيره دخول طارئه بالمجان وايضا يتمكنهم
المغادره ايضا هناك بعض
او معظم الاشخاص لا يحملون
جوازات او وثائق فيتم استخراج لهم تصاريح
وجوازات بعد التنسيق مع سفرات ام من
القنصرياتهم حتى يتمكننا من الخروج
والمغادره بسلا شكرا جزيلا لك هاني صفيان
مباشره من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
جده
هذا وامتد القتال الدائر في العاصمه
السودانيه امتد الى اقليم دارفور المضطرب
غربي البلاد حيث شهد اشتباكات متقطعه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع عدا عن
الفراغ الامني الكبير الامر الذي يثير
المخاوف من اندلاع حرب اهليه
ايقظ الصراع العسكري والدائر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ومحيطها صراعا اخر عمره
عقدان في الغرب البعيد من البلاد منطقه
دارفور
دارفور الواقعه في اقصى الغرب السوداني
تحظى بولاياتها الخمس باهميه استراتيجيه
كبيره لطرفي الصراع المتحاربين في السودان
فالاقليم يتشارك حدوديا مع اربع دول من
الغرب تشاد وليبيا ومن الجنوب افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان تسكن المنطقه قبائل
عده عربيه وافريقيه وسط وفره في الثروه
الزراعيه والحيوانيه والمعادن منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع منتصف ابريل تفاوت حجم العنف في
انحاء دارفور حيث تعرضت نيالا جنوب دارفور
والفاشر في الشمال لقتال عنيف في الايام
الاولى من الصراع لينحسر القتال فيهما
تدريجيا في الايام الاخيره ولينتقل بشده
وعنف الى مدينه الجنينه متسببا بمقتل ما
لا يقل عن 100 مدني وفق الامم المتحده
ومنظمات الاغاثه ونجد الاهتمام الدولي
يتركز اليوم على داركور التي شهدت نزاعات
قبليه قديمه ومتكرره حيث يظهر فراغ امني
كبير يخشى مراقبون من ان يؤدي الى حرب
اهليه
خاصه مع تزايد التسليح بين المدنيين
وافراد القبائل المتناحره عدا عن اعمال
النهب والتدمير واضرام الحرائق في المنازل
والمباني الحكوميه هذا فضلا عن مخاوف من
ان تلجا قوات الدعم السريع للاحتماء في
حاضنتها هناك اذا تازمت الامور في باقي
الولايات لتشتعل الامور اكثر في الاقليم
كل هذه تطورات دفعه الالاف من السكان
المحليين الى الفرار الى تشاد المجاوره
والى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بكل متاعهم
فيما يبدو وكانه رحيل بلا عوده
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
معنا مباشره من شرق دارفور الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه صالح اخر المستجدات حول هذه
الاشتباكات في دارفور
انا اليوم في جنوب دارفور في مدينه نيالا
اخر مستجدات التي نتحدث عنها
ونبدا منها هنالك احصائيه للقتل من
النازحين في غربي في الشمال دارفور مدينه
الفاشل اعلن فريق الطوارئ صحيه بمخيمة
شوقي للناجحين بمدينه الفاشر عاصمه شمال
دارفور ان حصيله
الجيش والقوات المسلحه بلغت 9 غسيل و 48
جريح هذا الصراع ايضا تدرب تسعه قتله تقصد
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
المواجهات اين اين بالتحديد
تسعه قتله من النازحين خلال المواجهات في
الفاشر خلال في الايام الماضيه في
الاسبوعين الماضيين هذه الحصيله التي تم
خلال الايام الماضيه من النازحين فقط في
الفاشر لكن اذا ما عرضنا على بقيه
الولايات سنجد ان ايضا الناجحين في اعاده
من الولايات تتضرر في جنوب دارفور والضرر
الاكبر في غربي دارفور حيث
نجح
ما يقارب المعسكرين او مركزين ايواء
للناجحين داخل المدينه نزول كلي هنالك
قتله وجرحه لم يتم احصائهم حتى الان نضبط
صعوبه الامور في غربي دارفور ونسبه لعدم
عوده الامن بصوره كامله في غربي دارفور
لكن حتى الان بعض المدن تشهد يعني حتى
نفهم المشهد في دارفور هل القصه مختلفه
عما يدور في السودان بمعنى انه الاقتتال
دائر هو بين الجيش والدعم السريع ام بين
القبائل العربيه وغيرها من الاثنيات
الاخرى
هذا في
عفوا هلا كررت الفكره هذا في غرف دارفور
ماذا قلت عذرا صوتك تقطع صالح
ابو علامه هل تسمعني
لم اتمكن من الاستماع الى اجابتك كنت تقول
ان الوضع في غرب دارفور كيف هو
نعم يعني فقط الصراع
الذي دار بين المكونات السكانيه
ونتج عنه
بهذا دارفور بعد معركه بين الجيش والدعم
الفريق تطور الى هذا الخلاف والان هنالك
مبادرات مجتمعيه على ارض الواقع تجري
لاحتواء هذا الصراع
وايجاد حلول وفتح ممرات امنه
وتسهيل
مهمه
الادارات الاهليه والقوات النظاميه ايضا
للنزول على
شارع في غربي لكن يعني كل هذه الجهود لا
لا تجد سنه تقوي من السلطات لا تجد وقفه
قويه خاصه في غربي دارفور
غياب تام
للاجهزه الامنيه غياب
للاجهزه الامنيه في غرب دارفور طيب لكن
صالح ماذا عن الحركات المسلحه سابقا التي
هي جزء من اتفاق جباء الذي انهى الاقتتال
الدائر في في دارفور
ما موقفها الان او هل لها اي دور في عدم
انزلاق الامور
اعمل حركات المسلحه تدخلت في شمال دارفور
تدخل
بقواتها ونزلت الى ارض الواقع وامنت جميع
مقرات المنظمات الموجوده في غرب دارفور
لان الان في في شمال دارفور في شمال
دارفور لم يتم نهب مقرات المنظمات العامله
منظمات الامم المتحده ذلك لتامين
الذي غرت به حركات مسار دارفور وهنالك
ايضا تمشيط لشوارع الفاشر لكن اتحدث قاده
الحركات الكساحه لانهم سيذهبون الى غرب
دارفور لكن حتى الان لم يسب اي فصيل الى
دارفور
للوقوف مع الاهالي في المحنه والخسائر
التي المت بهم جراء المعارك في الايام
الماضيه حتى حاتمي غين دارفور تحدث وفرح
وكتب هذا الحديث وقال سندخل بين
المتحاربين لكن يبدو ان الامر هنالك مختلف
ربما لم تتجه الحركات جميعها على ارسال
قوات الى ذلك المكان ربما لم تنسي غيبا مع
حكومه الولايه او ان هنالك ايضا رفض من
قبل ترفيه الصراع في غربي دارفور من تواجد
قوات يعني القوات مسار دارفور
جنينه لكن الايام القادمه ستكشف المزيد عن
هذه العمليه الوضع الانساني يحتاج الى
تدخل
يحتاج الى تدخل عاجل اليوم هنالك يعني
حركه لاعاده الكهرباء واعاده المياه في
الجنينه مياه مقطوعه وهذا هو هذه هي
ثمانيه ايام المياه مقطوعه الكهرباء
مقطوعه المستشفى مدمر لا يوجد دواء ولا
يوجد اطباء ولا يوجد وسيطه لعمل اي شيء في
غرب دارفور مدينه القنينه شكرا جزيلا لك
صالح ابو علامه الصحفي السوداني كنت معنا
من دارفور
اثار انتشار قوات الاحتياطيه المركزي جنوب
الخرطوم معركه كلاميه بين الشرطه وقوات
الدعم السريع التي اتهمت الشرطه بالوقوف
طرفا في الصراع في المقابل اكدت الشرطه ان
الاحتياطيه المركزيه هي قوات تابعه لها
وتعمل على تامين الاسواق والممتلكات
التابعه للمواطنين وضبط اي حاله فله امنيه
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي السوداني هي قوه
شروطيه تم انشاؤها عام 1990 وهي من
الادارات المهمه بقوات الشرطه وتقع
قيادتها بالكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم وتنتشر في
العاصمه والولايات تم تدريب عناصرها
للقيام بعمليات المسلحه وشاركت قبل اعوام
في عمليات قتاليه مع الجيش في ولايه
دارفور وجنوب كردفان هو النيل الازرق وشرق
السودان سلاحها اقرب للسلاح الجيش وبها
فرق عمليات خاصه تتدرب على يد القوات
الخاصه بالقوات المسلحه بدات الانتشار يوم
السبت بجنوب الخرطوم على ان يتوالى نزولها
لمناطق اخرى من العاصمه هذه القوات خاضعه
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ مارس من عام 2022
بتهمه استخدام القوه المفرطه ضد محتجين في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اول بدايه
في جسم بتاع الشرطه بعتنا محل الجسم طوال
دلوع الليله حرب جاي وبلونه دقيت لعيال
التلفون
قلتنا من هنا مشينا
معنا من اندرمان الصحفي شهدي نادر شهدي
اهلا بك معنا كيف تصف الوضع الامني بدايه
في اندرمان الان
مرحبا صهيب نعم انتهت يفترض ان تنتهي
اليوم خذناه وستبدا هدنه اخرى على مدارنا
قواعد الدعم السريع وايضا اعلنت القوات
المسلحه استجابتها وموافقتها على طلب
وساطه الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه بتمديد
الهدنه الاثنين وسبعين ساعه جديده اليوم
صهيب بدا هادئا هدوء النسبي كبير جدا في
مدينه ام درمان باستثناء جنوب ام درمان
وشرقها اليوم كانت هناك حركه في الشوارع
بدت مظاهر الحياه تعود بشكل
خفيف دعنا نعود ولكن بدات الشوارع تستعيد
على الطبيعي بشكل حذر عدد من المحاله التي
كانت مغلقه اليوم فتحت المحطات وقود لم
تكن تعمل اليوم
بدا بعضها يعاود العمل صهيب اليوم ودوا
الاشاره الى
تعرض السوق الشعبي في مدينه ام درمان الى
عمليه النهب طالت عدد من افر المصارف في
القابعه في هذا السوق اضافه الى متاجر
ومعارض تعرضت الى نقيب المجموعات
متفلته تستقل هذه الليله الاوضاع كما جرى
في مدينه الخرطوم بحري بدا الامر يتكرر
اليوم هنا في ينظلمان تحديدا في السوق
الشعبي
ملف الملف الانساني وتحديدا ملف الصحه
وما تزال هناك
مشاكل ربما
تتضاعف حال لما يتم تدارك الامر في ظل
الصعوبات التي تواجه المستشفيات
الطرفيه من غياب الاطباء
بدايه ندره
الادويه والمعينات الطبيه خصوصا ادويه
الامراض المزمنه اليوم
كان هناك حديث على اول شحنه مساعدات
انسانيه قد بدات تصل الى السودان عبر
ميناء بورسودان هل هناك اي نوع من
المساعدات بدات تدخل ام درمان
حتى الان لا توجد
لم تصل بعد كما تعلم
صهيبنا تحتاج الى تسميه مسارات امنه طرق
معينه نعم تحتاج للاجراءات حتى يتسنى لهذه
المشاهدات ان تصل الى المشافي او تصل الى
كل الى وجهته ان لم تكن مساعدات طبيه او
خلافه غذائيه او اي شيء اخر يحتاج الى
تحديد مسار امن بعيد عن اي مناوشات او اي
منتخب اشتباكات الاشكال الاخر في في الملف
الملف الصحي هو الضغط الواقع على
المستشفيات الطرفيه وبعد ان تم اخلاء
قالبيه مستشفيات وسط الخرطوم نتيجه هذه
هذه الاشتباكات
لا لا لا لا لا المرضى هناك مرافقيهم الى
الان يعني الجوا الى الالتجاء الى
المستشفيات الطرفيه ما زاد من العبا
الواقعه عليها في ظل اغلاق عدد كبير ما
يزال من المشاهد الخاصه التي كانت تحتمل
وتساعد القطاع الصحي هنا في السودان كثير
جدا منها
مغلق حتى حتى هذه حتى هذه اللحظه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك شهدي نادر مباشره من ام درمان
[موسيقى]
قال السفير السعودي لدى السودان علي بن
حسن جعفر لان خطه الاجلاء من السودان لا
تزال قائمه وفق القوائم التي تقدم او تم
تقديمها من قبل بعض الدول او السفارات
ووافقه طاقه الاستيعابيه للسفن والطائرات
كذلك علمت القياده
باحتياجات الانسانيه للانسان في
السودان
والخروجهم من مدينه
بسبب الاعمال القتاليه الراحله حتى صدرت
التوجيهات
باجلاء كل من يريد ان يتم اغلاق خلال فتره
واسست المملكه السفن والطائرات خطته الى
ما زالت قائمه لكنها
قوائل التي تقدم من قبل دونهم او سفارات
نحقق فيها حسب الطاقه الاستيعابيه
للسفن والطائرات التي ترسل يوميا
وفي بورسودان رصد مراسل العربيه نزار
البداوي احوال العالقين الذين ينتظرون
الخروج من البلاد نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي
عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول العربيه
والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق السودان الى
عدد من الدول في المنطقه اكثر من نحو عشره
الاف من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه تم اجلائهم
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه عبر ميناء
بورتسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من سته الاف
غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي الى
وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر السوريه
واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم في انتظار
استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها للبلاد احنا مو
طالبين اكثر من يتم اجلانه احنا مطالبين
من اي بلد يقعدوا يصرفهم شكرا احنا بس
بدنا ممر امن من هنا الى الحدود السوريه
وشكرا
البعض فضل البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل
والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه
على توفير دور مؤقته لاوائهم في ظل ظروف
يحاول الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه
بورسودان تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات
والنساء والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق
السودان نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه
والحدث مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات